House Republicans have launched a new
task force to look at the Chinese
government's role and potential
culpability in the spread of coronavirus
beyond China's borders back in December
joining me now is a member of that newly
formed brand new task force Florida
congressman Michael waltz congressman
thanks so much for your time today we
really appreciate it
yeah thanks Julian thanks for covering
this so as I understand it this new task
force is looking a little backwards
looking at what China's government knew
when they knew it and then it's also
looking a little forwards how to hold
the Chinese government potentially
accountable is that right yeah that's
right I mean this was clearly a cover-up
and and I think you will see a number of
groups help unfold what China has done
to unleash this virus and to not manage
it but I think we're also as you
mentioned looking forward and what I
like about this task force is it has rep
representatives from all over the
country all types of rural urban and
other districts and it covers a wide
variety of
midis everything from trade to finance
to health education of course military
because what China is doing as it
explicitly seeks to dominate a new world
order where it calls the shots not the
United States is it has a whole of
society whole-of-government approach and
that's how we're looking to combat what
they're doing from from the United
States perspective one thing the task
force doesn't have though is Democrats
and we've seen reports this week that
Speaker Pelosi originally was gonna join
up with you guys and was gonna be a
bipartisan task force but she later
reneged to tell us about what went wrong
well I don't know why she reneged but
this has been these negotiations been
ongoing from some time I think Democrats
absolutely should be involved this is a
national security issue in fact I think
this will be the national security issue
much like how we had to face the Soviet
Union for most of the 20th century this
will be the case for the 21st century
this shouldn't be about politics but I
think two things are at play here number
one
an intial election year Joe Biden is so
bad on this issue
he thinks the rise of China to compete
and eventually try to dominate America
is an okay thing he's on record many
times is doing that and then number two
this kind of narrative the Democrats
want to craft at any time we want to
deal with China it's a distraction from
their perspective of what they believe
were president Trump's failings and
that's just ridiculous this is about
dealing with what I think is the most
existential threat to the United States
to Liberty around the world to a free
world order that we've ever faced
so is the task force I guess this is
really a two-part question for you
number one is the task force planning to
do investigating of its own and then
number two is once you have a handle on
what the Chinese government knew about
the virus and when we got the facts and
the timeline ironclad are you gonna
present your findings to President Trump
or where do you hope to take it I guess
it's the question so will will
incorporate a lot of what the
intelligence community is doing will
receive a series of classified briefings
but I think what you'll see coming out
of this is really pulling together a
number of efforts Julian we've talked
about what we're trying to do to bring
our supply chain home chains home how
we're blocking our federal pensions and
even several dozen of our state pension
plans from investing in Beijing how
they're stealing our technology trying
to cut our companies out of business
economically and then of course compete
with us militarily so you know what
you're gonna see is pulling all of that
together birth some legislative packages
and then recommendations to the
president another really important
element of that package are working on
is seeking to hold the Chinese Communist
Party responsible for what you're
calling infiltration of US universities
tell us about the Chinese efforts on
that front
well you know I don't know many
Americans appreciate there's over
400,000 Chinese students in our
universities as we speak that doesn't
make them bad kids what they need to
understand is that they're victims the
Chinese Communist Party forces them to
vacuum up our Technology robotics
advanced materials artificial
intelligence and send it back to Beijing
where it gets fast tracking right to the
Chinese military that's one piece the
other pieces are actually recruiting
American professors through what they
call China's talents program these
professors are taking hundreds of
billions of dollars into their
institutions in reach taxpayer funded
research funding and these the bamps
technologies and then go in and
moonlighting over in Beijing's
universities including the Wuhan
Institute of Technology my legislation
seeks to stop both we cannot look the
China is looking to dominate us
technologically than economically and
then eventually militarily it's in
Chinese leadership writings and it has
to stop right well congressman we got to
leave it there an important message we
all know that whoever dominates and
artificial intelligence dominates the
future of the globe really so thanks for
bringing back to us and we will check
back with you soon I think you're still
realigning and all of this is a wake-up
pontil Ian thanks so much you bet